hey been pretty good it's been busy and
not everything with bangs
yeah man seems it oh well good I love
bands man I've let that [ __ ] kid I
think he's talented and so I've been on
the higher yeah and what's been going on
with you guys a lot of fun
yeah it seems like it that's so like
what do you want to happen
yeah it's a key on your psyche obviously
I have a structured long-term I'm doing
no it's alright how old are you it's so
crazy like my life right now with
everything it's going up done I'm
[ __ ] with all you kids like I'm like
I said to my friend my home is like no
shit's crazy I'm like yeah man he said
something funny is like you're popular
21 year olds with them when you were 21
like that's for sure
yeah it's so early right take advantage
the opportunities how did it all go down
give me the origin story started in high
school you know videos on the side like
a tumblr blog or a wordpress er like a
where it's what it's called
we're closed right from the get yeah and
what was the first premise of it did
blog so I was beating like what was the
blog about her tell me how I read every
school and just writing articles on you
local Chicago about music that's a
living about an hour and a half outside
the city okay
you know did that your high school built
the brand around my friends in school
yeah went out to see every weekend you
know that's not stickers throwing small
events with what I could move to the
city after I graduated college DePaul
just expanded everything going school
was always about that yeah and then you
know what was the first good moment
first good moment
just like selling out I think like the
venues in Chicago that always went to
like in just like kind of building up
the ladder like I wonder if I could one
day thought that one then Kopelman's
late
Oracle months later we're selling out
those menu you woke up and you were
curating the Daleks oh yeah their
climate shows no accurate town oh this
is pretty got a good show what are you
putting on I could lose you very
spiritual and Chicago ever my sophomore
year of college
it sold out and like after that I think
in terms of shows you know everything
skyrocketed so fast so and you were you
knew like how long have you guys known
each other I've known for about three or
four years this crazy complete they met
because new girl Emily was just starting
in Chicago who's they're starting to get
a nice little buzz and I was like he's
older than me so I still in high school
I was like just loved everything going
on so I'm on the write for the blog
again I reduced during a show it was at
18 plus though when I was like hey I was
only 17 so I went I'm at some little
beggars day and I a sponsor I turn 18
like is it okay if I come to show could
you help me do could you help get me in
that's cool
and what about you know this is another
artist I manage is Nader I'm so cold
we just met through so kind of same way
I met bands I actually met both in
advance both through a group chat on
Twitter and what's up we've all just
been super close
what do you live I live in Iran it's
good man good for you let's meet you
okay I'm a good week how long you been
here
I was that in New York this morning
first time before what's been going on
with you my mother finally
good for you excited yeah yeah
send me some links I'd love to listen I
know I'm sure where's Boyd the last
thing I thought you're gonna say the
first of many yeah of course of course
okay so that's what's happened hmm
you know starting to close the
merchandise and God's work was a lot of
local Chicago acts at the time I don't
know just kind of inspects Louie
of course I work with these heavy guys
and um one thing kind of led to another
you know was working with a lot of local
acts and things just started coming
together and um I was able to start
traveling a little bit I went to LA
worked on video with Soulja Boy do you
know Soulja Boy's probably the reason
like all this is happening for me you
know the soldier boy for you know the
soldier boy Boyd and my brother story my
boy met my brother like second day of
college at peace at BU and like five
minutes in they got into some sort of
conversation where Boyd was like I know
who the next rappers are gonna be and
age it was like yeah if you're such a
big shot why don't you tell me who's
next then Boyd went in his room spent
like two days in my space didn't go to
class came out was like this guy and was
soldier boy crazy legend for especially
for this genre like he started like a
yeah he was a different flavor that
became the standard mm-hmm for sure okay
so it was worked with a lot people the
music videos start to get me and
put all the videos out through my
channel a YouTube channel and you know
to kind of go to the point where is
becoming a platform I've worked my a lot
of artists and you know the kept getting
bigger and bigger and kind of hand
picking you know the artists we work
with and make sure it's very organic and
just thought that we genuinely enjoy you
know Sargon big the merchandise starts
out last week you know shows got bigger
you know we're just kind of just a
domino effect from there got to start
working with a lot of people and then
like early 2017 late 2016 I started
working with I don't a lot of times
people from low pumps of Perkin Warhol
and a lot of that no jumper kind of like
but yeah yeah I might know a jumper
interview there on then I was found
working with all these people and it was
still like a very much underground thing
but a lot I brought it but it wasn't to
the point where it's at now and then
over the course of two months everything
just kind of picked up and you know tall
dark and big and everything else went
with it and now the DD Tube channel give
two million subscribers in the next
couple of days so that's really cool and
she's kind of building a bunch of
different types of content around what
are you gonna put all this energy
against you think are you want to build
a media platform a merchandise platform
yes yes yes like do you want to start a
label like what do you thinking about
putting what like so for example if you
asked me that question like what am i
doing people always like are you
starting a label are you gonna sort of
management companies especially if I
want to buy brand like I'm doing all
this
like the business slower like k-swiss
which like Mike's neat like I'm gonna
buy a business and I'm gonna try to do a
champion did right take a brand that
used to be something then became
[ __ ] and bring it back so that's
what I'm doing like the way I want to
like really build my thing is build a
machine but then point it against
Snickers or Yahoo and so like I feel
like in the same way that you call these
people got big like I'm gonna try to do
that with I'm in a bad relationship with
everybody and then there's gonna be a
crescendo moment when I buy like blow
pops and I'm gonna want every athlete
every rap or every business person you
know what I mean
I know what's happening my book this
book is number three in the world right
now today like this is the number three
Sun book in the world on Amazon right
now it's happen right now and I'm not
even hustling it's just all from the
love like every Instagram so you know so
there's everything's you Avenue you know
so the merchandise is going incredibly
well you know every releases selling out
quick well I don't know make money yeah
that's you know what I think suddenly
but I have an idea of what I wanted that
to be and then with the events you know
we're working a summer festival in
Chicago right now but every year we get
all their clothes you know saba huh you
know saba yeah I like that kid so much
he's such a nice kid off he's my he's my
man he was the first one that like drop
my name in a song his Monday is Monday
to Monday the first person you know I'm
a big fan I know I like Chicago yeah the
chance thing must've been cool for you
to watch I'm so in the craziest right I
got into a lot of this I believe it I
love all that yeah yeah I see that
thank for everybody in Chicago like
chance especially for audience chance to
play such a people so much so it's like
just so experienced so much so just you
do I don't know who like a know Sabah
but like from afar and I know pretty
well Chicago yeah it just seems normal
until you kind of step back you know
yeah you realize what you working and
things come along like I think there's a
lot of inspiration for me you know I
know is there anything I can help what I
I head of a loose idea so like I said
the company is really big and in terms
of what it is you know I get it
so it's like I said the merchandise is
so big and it's just in such demand and
just like the company and everything
it's just like a very exclusive item
that I feel like it's just there's
there's just a want for it and I've been
wanting to I've been reaching out to
people I think it would be crazy to make
actual their lemonade and and to to even
just do it like a small run just just
show good that's smart
I know it's smart I know you work with
brands everyone uh-huh p-put it I just
you know I just wanted to talk that idea
out to you beyond that as market talking
like partner on something or just do you
want me to help you just like I'm funny
I'm funny like I can run the gamut of
like being really involved or just
really introducing the right people and
being a rabbi and getting you off I was
I was kind of just open to what he
thought of it before I I think it's a
really good idea I think like think
about it right and if you did it really
right if you did it really right and
like at like this would be something
that I would I would I would ask for
favors like this is where you cash in
chips like whenever you launch it not
only launch it the way every
as you know it's gonna be successful
because you got eyes but this is exactly
like all like like if you and Izzy like
kept the relate like this is when you
cash in chips because you have to
understand that's a big business if
you've got a beverage this is big right
this business is gonna do cheer from
zero which means itself I don't think
you probably don't understand that this
young of an age how big successful
beverage businesses are worth you can
sell dollars with the hoodies and work
that your lemonade and your lemonade
company will suffer a lot more I know
because it's two men game Pepsi and Coke
I don't want anybody entering dr.
peppers company just so just like little
New York eliminate carnies yeah man
people would [ __ ] with it heavy a little
bit about it so I sent him that I could
send you guys whatever else you need I
can help you
I can help you trying to think about who
and what and where and what you can kill
it it's a smart idea
I think non-alcoholic no I think that's
right wants to become something tangible
and a sense of you can drink it it's
actually real emanate I think it just
stays with you
I think it's super interesting I mean I
think I here's what I would say too many
people rush to switch
I like your general energy of not
switching to early yeah
it's keep Billy 21 the longer you can
just keep doing it about them you win
but yeah I mean like the like your
ability with the kind of things I'm
hearing and I got to do a little more
homework I mean I know about it but like
excuse me your ability to build the
coachella of like this genre is real
that's real [ __ ] business you can do
anything it's all about attention it
just comes down to you I said in the
last meeting some people want to make 5
million and go to Jamaica and smoke weed
for rest their life and some people want
to build empires like I don't know and
then everything in between right like
its authenticity of everything that
really keeps me going you want to still
live in where do you live
gr and you want to stay there long term
you think does that lay in New York pull
you I like la la New York no but I like
Chicago PC grounded I can come to LA and
do a ton of work on New York kind of
work then go back Chicago so fit in
fully work on it then I'm ready come
back out here just keeps me organized
and what do you guys have a relationship
like official yeah with the camera so
yeah we are like four I like a small
team and yeah he's 21
I'm 20 everyone you work with is our age
and we've all been just working
from moments kids like on our computers
again a mentorship then we finally
recently discovered our own space so
we're kind of all together for once like
the whole time this comes yeah they're
like this is the first time we're all
together really putting our ideas
together really I really haven't thought
about it's just an idea how do you want
to sell it
I think selling it through I think you
know website the first round of
everything can be through the internet
like other web store just like a Shopify
yeah just too excited that's right gage
you know what the potential of it is
from there and all these kids will [ __ ]
with you and give you love right yeah
yeah everything you've ever put out it
sells out within half an hour's few
minutes a few minutes yeah it's best
something you should be making a little
more sounds gonna be something a little
more a few minutes of fast
yeah like you mean exactly like what are
we talking about how much volume what
where that we use is I think that having
the demand is important so we first
overstock of course you know 1,500 easy
eight minutes that's [ __ ] good wow
that's a lot yeah this piece here on
that stuff sold out so fast man
unfamiliar grilled of course so right
after we dropped it within like 15
minutes there's like screenshots of
people who had bought the sweater like
putting on real art each other you start
seems when I kind of realize like wow
like this is real yeah it's what
happened like a Swiss is come on eBay
and stuff right yeah yeah yeah just like
don't you like you want something you
want some business mentorship
yeah because you feel like you're going
to the next place yeah I could taste
like I was getting lost in YouTube
videos I just find inspiration from it
and and I just feel like there's there's
a lot of overlap that could be found
every other yeah
sport that's what you just looked into
everything a little more okay well
actually interested in it okay well huh
check it out more
oh well oh well okay six and photos
let's do it
you kids like seven that's a cerveza hey
I'll be good
yeah how would you gauge man my man I'm
really looking forward to not some
senator [ __ ] good to see you man all
right talk to you soon
[Music]